[音楽]
スパ
花屋さん今日はたしますよ
超ね
加瀬ますよズキンとせんだよなぁじゃあ活用巨
悪いけどそれっとに去年さらにが以前あった分です
を4番8番
いやーラバー去年は2回戦で負けたんでお知らせより大きいてるようにちょっと頑張り
たいと思います
貴様らがたどり着けなかった領域に笑っていやでもそれもうあれですよ一さんと1回戦
で負けたら
インターなんでみんな
俺ちゃんですかああああああ
以下表人材を屋さんが1回戦負けていったフレーズをレッツと優勝する気で来たんで
こう今日は
いきます忘れ物ないすか
多分ないと思うはいオッケーほっぺ大丈夫で家もぜひさえあればなんとかなるところだ
ああ
影が出来ました髪もっと持ったサイコロとコインいきますはい
つきましたちょっと小さめの会場ですが
頑張ってみますできありますかインバル
ん
ああああああ
フェル本当はん
are you はい行きますバンドさんとフリッツ屋さん
すっぽりカフェでありますくるわけですね
wh
me これは
ジャガースーパーさん
たら地面3位
ai
言われるんだ林れた
僕の設備があるんだ
越前18年6月に開催される日本大の決定戦出場する権利を得ます制限時間終了してん
じゃないポイントの優劣があってもそのターン終了まで継続する03終了してね処理が
払底したければ
京都は8すぎる
ブービーですかああぬー jk
bejean
tee
wh
すべて気はございません
me
[拍手]
[音楽]
ああああああ
pareja a
dengon
ねただ
はい
ですねーよ僕にとってああ
フーゴ行ってらっしゃいでしたね一体せてからエンツォ入って
第コインとか微量のたで勝ちましたそのウルボーグリー
いやーは囲碁を渋谷ます戦後の俺最後のヴェーラー結構頑張ったと思うとした
when ん
bejean
ん
ありましたいいいいいいいいいい
bjerg いい
amaran
me
おいで誰かがバーナバス器用な嫌がらせをやらかしにな歌詞を重ねたね
東海予選静岡県の代表を決める権大会ですね
2回戦で
安息わけで負けましたありがとうござ
何やってんだ俺いいです僕のことはもうのも知ってください2年連続できてアドラで
あの日素数が本当に馬鹿の体位
うーんまいつも参加したんですよね2018年のなんか世界大会の3バーもらいました
いやーもうもったいないの一言に尽きるんですけどまぁそこも含めての有業なんで
仕方ないなとは思っております言い訳とかっていうわけじゃないですけどちょっと
始めるのが遅かったなっていうふうに思いました結局ねゆ行っていうのでコツコツと前
に製茶
てるてるとか活メジャー結構直前でめちゃくちゃ朝までやったり練習しまくったんです
けどやっぱりまだ時間が足りなくて
そういう店が起きてしまったのではないでしょうかまた基礎のかな
阿蘇ジオなんかたるんでた部分があって反則負けしたのかなと思いますマナー反則負け
なんですねその
故意的ななんかズレしてやろうと思ってやったやつじゃなかったんでその一発退場見
たいわけじゃなかったんですけど結果的にもう戻れないんでそれでも号車もないねって
て負けちゃった
監視でございます最後ああいう権大会の場でギリギリでも風たんで良かったです
できれば雄三しただけ1勝だけでもすごいことだと思うんですけども
反則負けしたらもったいないなっていうか極度の巾着を緊張じゃないですよね緊張する
のがや
去年と同じ場所で止まっちゃったんですけども逆に言うと去年より下がってないんであ
クラスに考えてアインでも機会があれば頑張りたいと思っております
みました動画をずっとこうやって見てますから女性ピリピリした互いがすごいああもう
癖になって楽しいですよ
4来年も頑張りマースそれぞれ話ないようにしようっ
[音楽]
me
バッハ